I was chosen for the
female protection team
four years ago.
I can't express how excited I was.
It was my dream, and the dream comes true.
(upbeat electronic music)
I'm first corporal
Omneyat Dawood Sulaiman.
I'm working in Dubai police
in security, emergency,
and protect department.
- [Female Narrator] The pioneering,
all-female elite squad's
role is to protect visiting VIPs
at the big events in the UAE.
Their training includes
hand-to-hand combat,
firearms, and the kind of driving skills
that put Hollywood stuntmen to shame.
These women have safeguarded over 500 VIPs
on more than 1,000 occasions.
- [Omneyat] We're 30 female in the unit,
and there's different teams.
We have the bikers and the drivers.
I'm one of the bikers.
- [Female Narrator] These
highly-skilled women
go through rigorous training and only
the very best can hope to earn a place
in the elite squad, but for Omneyat,
law enforcement is more than just her job.
- [Omneyat] I decided
to be a police officer
when I was 16 years old.
My mom and most of my
family members are in police
and as well in the army.
I am Ghuson Sulaiman Abdula Almahmood.
My rank is a major.
I was one of the first female
officer in Dubai police.
When my daughter became part
of the VIP protection unit,
I was so proud.
My granddaughter, she
also like to be police.
It will be three generation.
Me and my daughter and
my daughter daughter.
- [Female Narrator] It's
not hard to see the appeal.
These women have an important
and exciting role here,
and although it's a demanding
and disciplined life,
working and living in
this 21st century city
has its own rewards.
- [Omneyat] I love Dubai and
everyone, whether they are VIP
or a regular person, they
have to feel safe in Dubai,
and we will keep helping them
because we are the protection team.